you know prolonged fasting is so
beneficial for your immune system
or getting rid of cancer or brain health
or anti-aging but there's one aspect of
prolonged fasting that is fairly
dangerous okay you could potentially die
and I need to make you aware of this so
it's called refeeding syndrome what is
that that's a situation where at the end
of this prolonged fast let's say you
fasted for four days you eat too much
too fast and the wrong Foods okay that
could be the problem but before I get
into this I do want to point out
something
this usually involves someone who has
malnutrition someone who maybe has an
eating disorder someone who is an
alcoholic someone who maybe has been a
diabetic type one for a long period of
time or someone who has been starving
okay which is different than a prolonged
fast but if you are following my
recommendations the risks of you having
this problem are very very low because
you're not going into this having
malnutrition I always recommend when you
do fasting any type of fasting that you
at least as a bare minimum take
electrolytes and number two B vitamins
because a lot of studies indicate people
who have this syndrome
um usually have really poor nutritional
reserves but I don't know your situation
I don't know
how your diet has been in the past I
don't know what you're taking so this
video is very very important for
everyone who is prolonged fasting other
than dying you could potentially get a
coma seizures convulsions but again
these things are rare so here's what
happens in this situation
you go into a long-term fast let's say
it's three four five days or longer now
typically if you check the blood the
person is going to be fine they're not
going to have any deficiencies of
minerals electrolytes or any of these
things right but you have to realize
that the great great majority of certain
minerals like potassium magnesium
phosphorus are inside the cell not in
the blood so like 95 to 98 of those
minerals are inside the cell so as
you're doing fasting okay the body is
going to be releasing all these minerals
or electrolytes from the cell into the
blood to keep them at a certain level
that's your body's stable kind of
reference point always keep the blood
normal despite pulling nutrients from
the cells from your bone from your
muscles so when you get a blood test for
these electrolytes or nutrients you're
not actually testing the inside of your
cells the intracellular you're checking
the extracellular nutrients right in
your blood so you're not going to really
know what's happening inside the cell
unless you do a intracellular test
but if you're fasting for any period of
time a lot of these nutrients don't get
stored for a long period of time a lot
of them aren't fat soluble okay they're
water soluble so you may find in a
period of time they can go down pretty
fast especially if when you eat your
diet has been poor in the past or you
don't focus on getting nutrient dense
foods then you decide you know what I
hear all these great things about doing
a prolonged fast I'm going to do a four
or five day fast you do the fast you
don't take your electrolytes you don't
take your B vitamins
and then it's time to eat okay and you
just pig out you start eating all sorts
of things and lots of things like
carbohydrates sugar whatever at this
point you can develop What's called the
refeeding syndrome okay and what is
happening is you're very quickly raising
insulin not to mention being on that
four or five day fast your insulin
sensitivity has become extremely
sensitive those receptors are ready to
pull in these nutrients from your blood
very quickly and what happens is you
have this this rapid shift of
electrolytes specifically phosphorus
that's the big one potassium and
magnesium sometimes calcium okay and all
of this shifts from the blood to the
inside of your cell to replace what's
missing and you end up with extremely
low electrolytes in the blood and this
is what puts the stress on the heart
okay okay and this is what also can
increase edema and swelling because you
have this imbalance
you see when you're fasting you have
very low insulin because when you have
low insulin you actually get rid of a
lot of fluid and sodium and with some
people it could be 11 20 pounds 30
pounds of fluid okay that's a lot
but when you start eating okay and your
insulin stress going up you start
retaining sodium as well so this is
where you can get some edema as well all
of a sudden you're you start holding
fluid and you're you're like what is
going on here and on top of that if
you're eating a lot of carbs these carbs
are going to be converted into glycogen
and glycogen needs potassium
to store this sugar so you're going to
use up a lot of this potassium from the
food you eat and not to mention all this
shift from the blood into the cells you
end up with a very low level of
potassium you're also going to be
storing fat as well as protein and both
of those macronutrients need vitamins
and minerals as well so you deplete
those and you also deplete vitamin B1 in
a big way when you do carbs the
metabolism of carbs requires B1 as the
cofactor
and so anytime you eat carbs you just
deplete your B1 big time and one of the
big symptoms from a B1 deficiency is
memory loss okay and that can create
confusion it could create anxiety and a
whole host of other issues that relate
from all the way over here from
neurological problems to heart problems
and so that's the Simplicity of what the
refeeding syndrome is so how do we
prevent this problem from happening well
make sure number one when you're eating
you're doing the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet you're doing nutrient
dense foods number two take electrolytes
and the B vitamins as a bare minimum
while you're fasting it might also be
good to take other things too like olive
oil to get you fat soluble vitamins as
well as your omega-3 fatty acids it
might be also good to take vitamin d and
vitamin K2 as well as some trace
minerals and that way you're not going
to have malnutrition okay so it's going
to help you and when you introduce food
you go slowly I'm talking about maybe an
egg okay and you wait a couple hours and
you eat something else maybe you have a
a little bit of soup okay wait a couple
more hours and do I don't know some
sauerkraut okay and then wait a little
bit and do a little bit of nuts so that
first day you don't want to do more than
like half of your normal calories okay
so let's say you're doing a thousand
calories on the first day and then you
slowly increase food the next several
days now this all depends on how long
that you fast
if you fasted for a long period of time
let's say you fasted for 21 days or 30
days well you're going to go even slower
than if you fasted for three or four
days
now just realize that when you're doing
intermittent fasting like say one meal a
day you don't have to worry about this
okay I'm talking about when you fast for
three four five days in a row so now
that you know the dangers and how to
prevent this refeeding syndrome
the next thing to really wrap your wits
around is the benefits of prolonged
fasting so I put that video up right
here check it out